the University of Maryland is allowing
its football coach to return to the
field after the death of a player the
school's board of regents yesterday
reinstated coach DJ Durkin against the
university president's recommendation
burkan was placed on administrative
leave in August after an ESPN report
into allegations of a toxic culture in
the University of Maryland football
program the report followed the death of
offensive lineman Jordan McNair the 19
year old suffered heatstroke in a
practice in May and died later in the
hospital an independent investigation
concluded the football culture was not
toxic but it did find many students
feared speaking out about the grueling
program Mayer's family demanded Durkin
be fired I feel like I've been punched
in the stomach and somebody spit in my
face some players also had issues with
retaining Durkin offensive lineman Ellis
McKenney tweeted a group of people do
not have the courage to hold anyone
accountable for his death in a statement
the coach wrote I'm grateful for the
opportunity to rejoin the team also
yesterday University of Maryland
president Wallace Lowe announced he
would retire at the end of the academic
year know I'm a proud graduate of
University of Maryland I hear a lot of
people are upset even some players on
the team actually walked out of a
meeting yesterday you'll be interesting
to see if if this decision stands yeah
and how the team coheres around somebody
there that's so sad